admit they are not the Patriotic Party
in fact just 37 percent of the left
thinks America is the greatest country
in the world instead most think the US
is just great but not the greatest on
the other hand nearly 70 percent of
Republicans say America is the goat
which I think is a sports reference
greatest of all time obvious country yes
I just don't know why they didn't ask a
follow-up question if it's not America
what country is it now I've been told
not to single out individual countries
for ridicule so I'm not going to do that
but if you just take politics out of it
look at this country
it's got the best weather
it's got the best entertainment
it's got the best products got the best
fashion the best cuisine
even if you're a far left radical you're
shaking your head with Italy come on
you're shaking your head it's got the
best I said I wasn't going to do it but
I did but I mean it's got everything you
need in terms of the total package maybe
one or two countries is a little bit
better this or that we're talking total
package nothing better than it has the
idea Harold that life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness that's what makes
it the greatest I don't think it's any
dad that you can come up with quotes as
Jesse comes with all the time but from
himself and then repeats him again on
the show only in America can you do that
I think look the the I should beat
another character I think we're the
greatest greatest of the greatest of all
time and anyone that doesn't
um you know people have every right
every right to do it Joey when he's on
here he says like I go to war to defend
people uh to give people the freedom to
say whatever they want to say about the
country whatever they want to say about
me you just have to hope that we get to
a point where I don't care which party
you're in you believe that this country
is the one the one country you can
change things and make things better
that's why we're the greatest in the
world a couple of years ago judge I was
at this event and this guy sitting next
to me let's have a nice little Chit Chat
they were talking about the country and
he I said well what do you think the
biggest problem is in the country and he
said the Constitution and then it was a
very chilly dinner yeah I'll bet it was
you know I would ask people well if you
don't think this is the greatest country
what is the greatest country and if it's
not a great country why are you living
here why aren't you living in the
country that you think is the greatest
country and my last question would be
are you saying that the people who gave
their lives and for this country and
fought and and lost limbs are you saying
that they're stupid that they did it for
an average country for a not so great
country you know it it it I find it very
offensive it's weird that millions of
people around the world are trying to
get here they think it's the greatest I
think you have to go backwards too and
and it's like you don't you shouldn't
ask you have to ask them where did you
get this belief and where did where they
got the belief is they got it in school
they're being indoctrinated by teachers
who feel this way and feel that we're
the land of the oppressed we're the land
of the oppressor and you are the
oppressed if you are not if you are um
you know if you're coming from somewhere
else so I think that to prevent this
from growing and permanently damaging
the country we do need school choice
school choice will solve this because
right now they're only hearing one side
of the story you know we got rid of the
Pledge you know we're getting rid of the
Pledge of Allegiance people are not
doing it as much you know and we're
replacing with other stuff drag queen
story time which I by the way am for
because that's how I make extra money
let us know the schedule we'll be there
yeah hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else